beau Casper Smart opens up about his
acting career and ex-girlfriend Jennifer
Lopez just feel blessed
Petey spoke with the 29 year old dancer
while he was in New York to help launch
lazes new poppable snack by
choreographing a special dance session
we're gonna do like a little um little
pop dance we're gonna just some fun and
light like the probable snack and and
have fun it so he obviously loves
dancing the creative director is
currently focusing on his acting career
he'll be starring in ABC's Dirty Dancing
remake out later this year but I'm also
very proud to be part of something so
iconic and legendary but does he miss
tour life with ex Jennifer Lopez that
was my last dance job it was tiring but
very nice to be able to like travel the
entire world in six months especially
with someone you're with and you'd enjoy
together as for how beau would describe
their relationship now good friends
nothing but like respect and love for
each other
in fact he's happy for JLo and her
budding romance with former Yankee star
Alex Rodriguez always nothing but I want
nothing but the best and love you know
you